the lands between offer many mysteries
for us to explore from decaying ruins to
cryptic war monuments there is no
shortage of events and people whose
stories we can delve into and research
this can be the lore of demigods the
timeline of the shattering or anything
else that lies under the surface of the
lands between and when it comes to the
less grandiose foes the average joes of
the world as opposed to the towering
demigods a few stand out for their
extreme dearth of information there are
the worm faces greater and lesser
skulking about with a disappearing rise
there are the cemetery shades
embodiments of death and infested with
crab spiders but beyond even these
enigmatic enemies there is another that
seems to be even less blessed with
exposition
they are found throughout the lands
between popping up in more areas of the
game than any other enemy probably they
are always on guard standing look out
over their territory these creatures of
the watch that i want to discuss in this
video might be the most mysterious enemy
in all of elden ring and they go by many
names
abnormal stone clusters according to
fecturelite a live stone according to
the game's internal file names and
mihari ishii according to the japanese
game guide in this video i invite you to
join me as we do our best to sleuth out
the lore and information of the enemy
with literally no written lore or
in-game reference let's find out what
these one-eyed stone lookouts really are
and as we begin i just want to note that
you can subscribe to the channel to stay
up to date with my content and doing so
helps the channel out also a thank you
to my patrons who support me on patreon
and now let's begin our investigation
[Music]
miharishi
[Music]
as my title suggests i think this enemy
might be the entity in the game with the
absolute least description
previous discussions have noted some
enemies like wormface and the cemetery
shades as being pretty sparse on info
and lore but these enemies seem to have
a bit of an edge over our stoneworms the
cemetery shades are referenced and
described by the mantis blade which is
dropped by the lesser shades it
describes them as insect-ridden grave
keepers
wormface follows a similar story of
having greater and lesser versions but
goes down a peg in opacity considering
no lore or item descriptions reference
them however they are not completely
devoid of in-game reference since the
boss fight in the altus plateau does
give us their insulting and almost
juvenile name of wormface but unlike
both of these enemies the stones get
literally no reference description or
name according to the game they have no
item reference for any details and no
boss form to offer a name the text dump
of the entire game leaves no trace
either most players won't have anything
definitive to even call these creatures
in a playthrough
so we have a good of a starting point as
any a name as the game gives us nothing
we have to look elsewhere
somehow fextralife decided to call these
creatures abnormal stone clusters i
don't know where fextra chose this name
or gets their names from but it is
explanatory if a bit dry
the game's internal file names goes for
a bit less informative and a bit more
comedic with the very straightforward
alive livestone all one word but neither
of these likely count as the official
name of the enemy thanks to my fellow
creator the lore hunter we have a photo
of this enemy's page in eldon ring's
japanese game guide and wouldn't you
know there seems to be a name there too
google translate says the japanese reads
as mihari ishii don't know if i
pronounce that right and in english that
translates to either guardstone or
lookout stone in terms of effect these
lethargic worms don't do much guarding
but we can say that they function
somewhat as lookouts so i'll go with
lookout stone for the rest of the video
and there we go we at least have a name
for the subject of our search look out
stones
not much but better than alive stones i
guess now that we have a name we can try
to piece it together with the other
information we have about the enemies it
isn't much but we do have some
environmental info along with their item
drops i'll wait on their drops for now
but the environment does tell a story
these stones are almost exclusively
placed around ever jails throughout the
lands between we can find them as early
as limb grave or as late as the
mountaintop of giants but in almost
every case they surround ever jails the
only exception to this rule is near the
deep chauffeur well but we'll return to
that later too
encircling every ever jail in the game
makes sense for these stones now that we
have their name they are lookouts for
the ever jails making sure no prisoner
escapes kind of and yes if you didn't
know these are called ever jails not
ever goals or ever gowls or any other
odd pronunciation jail g-a-o-l is
another way to spell jl j-a-i-l
it's an older spelling that is still
used in some places like i know ireland
has historic jails like kilmainium jail
and that's spelled with the gaol
spelling so these are jails which house
inmates of a kind and the lookout stones
are likely standing guard or at least
serving as lookouts the sole eye on each
one helps sustain the idea that they're
lookouts keeping an eye out for any
trouble and exploding in case it comes
about though as you may have realized
they're not great at their job they
won't explode if you don't attack them
so they don't do much guarding or
functional looking out they stand
glowing at attention to ever jails which
house their inmates but once you kill
these locked in troublemakers the stones
become more passive or at least that's
what i thought happened i wrote that
line before checking and now i've just
checked it in game and the stones don't
seem to stop looking out or glowing
after killing the inmate so they're
probably just glitched out in general or
i forgot some step if i did let me know
in the comments
if we instead assume that they're still
working out as intended it seems the
stones may be chill with you
slaughtering the inmates so maybe
they're only on lookout for breakouts
but we do actually get to free someone
from an ever jail live near the end of
ronnie's quest and they don't attack or
react then or at least i'm pretty sure
they don't so maybe it's better to
assume that they just aren't working
properly
the stones don't do much else they'll
attack if attacked but they just slink
around otherwise considering this we
aren't going to get much more
information from them directly so now
let's look at the evergles they guard
the magic they seem to be imbued with
and the items they drop one of the most
distinct features of these alive stones
is their purple glow and employment of
what seems like gravity magic we see
that every other instance of gravity
magic from spells to radon and the
alabaster and onyx lords is the same
kind of purple color so with the
consistency that fromsoft employs it
seems almost certain that the lookout
stones are using gravity magic and this
provides a connection between the stones
and the onyx and alabaster lords who i
will from here on out use
interchangeably we know the lords or at
least one of them taught radon how to
use gravity magic and from their
alabaster lord sword we learn that they
are a race of ancients with skin of
stone who are said to have risen to life
when a meteor struck long ago the remark
about skin of stone further cements the
connection between these lords and the
lookout stones it seems pretty sensible
that beans with stone skins and wielding
gravity magic would create automatons
made of stone that also wield gravity
magic we will come back to see more of a
connection with the alabaster lords and
evergles but i want to quickly bring up
the other automatons of the lands
between for comparison you may remember
that there are some other stone enemies
throughout the world like the golems
urgently burial watchdogs and the imps
we might be tempted to draw a connection
between these golems and our featured
guardstones but we must be careful in
doing so here i'll point out a really
comprehensive reddit post by user rocket
luco who explored the ancient
civilizations of the lands between
including ideas about the creation of
the guardstones and the golems rocket
notes that many of the items around the
golems like the golem grepo for instance
refer to a civilization now gone to ruin
the bose description also says that it
is made of black stone not too far of a
cry away from onyx lords with skins of
stone a uniting aspect of all of these
golem creatures is that they are
affected by crystal darts throw enough
of these energized projectiles and any
of these stone golems will turn frenzied
attacking anything near them this
applies to each of this new group of
stone automatons but it doesn't work on
the lookout stones throw crystal darts
at them and they remain inert only
responding as they would to a normal
attack with no frenzy effect provoked to
me this draws a definite distinction
between the lookout stones and the other
golem constructs they are to some degree
of a different kind the question though
is whether this distinction is enough to
make us think that the lookout stones
were made by someone or some group other
than those who made the gollum
constructs
rocket leuko points out that the stone
construct magical light engine motif
which is found in the golems is also
present in the elevators of the
chauffeur well entrances and somewhat at
the divine towers as well there are also
stone etchings in these areas that we'll
see maybe could bear similarity to the
evergles maybe rocket theorizes that
these were created by some ancient
mechanical construct civilization which
they later posit may simply be one in
the same with the onyx and alabaster
lords while i understand the connection
it's hard for me to come to the same
conclusion at least without any
hesitations the lookout stones do have
the same stone powered by magical light
motif but their visual presentation is
different the purple gravity light does
not appear in any of the golems or
elevators even though it would have been
a perfect use case for powering
elevators as they are completely gravity
dependent obviously they're going up and
down on the axis of gravitational pull
and looking closer at the evergles
things keep getting complicated the
evergles also feature the stone powered
by light motif but like the lookout
stones they are purple
but to be fair their entrance light does
actually have a bit of a blue hue to the
purple color though once we get inside
the purple coloring becomes stronger and
as an aside there are also these runes
or scripts on the evergel seal i don't
know where else we can find this kind of
etching in game it looks familiar to me
but i can't place it or find a match
after searching if any of you recognize
this as something you've seen elsewhere
in the game please point out in the
comments and then that might elucidate
some connection that the ever jails have
to other things in the game okay end of
aside and when we enter the evergles to
fight their prisoners we see another
connection to the stone lords each
prisoner comes into being with a purple
black aura surrounding them we can see a
similar effect when we come across the
stone lores outside of the jails such as
in the lake of rot the crater park glade
and lim grave or the pronunciation
pending yellow annex tunnel in the
consecrated snow field we could also
even theorize that what keeps all of the
inmates in these jails is some
utilization of gravity magic that pulls
them in to keep them trapped
with all of these connections even if
the last one is pretty tenuous it seems
only right for us to conclude that the
ever jails were originally made by the
alabaster lords this theory fits since
the stone skin lords are ancient beings
from this we should also probably
surmise that the lookout stones which
exist in such close connection with the
evergles and seem to use gravity magic
were also fashioned by these same lords
that then gives us the creators of the
lookout stones another piece of info
arrived at for an enemy with no explicit
lore or reference we are making progress
even if it seems slight
as i said rocket luco thinks the
alabaster and onyx lords may be the same
as the mechanical construct civilization
which built the wells and divine towers
i still think it's contentious due to
the differences but i do have to admit
that the only place we find a host of
lookout stones outside of evergel areas
is in caled in the ravine housing the
deep chauffeur riverwell
also in the area are a few golems which
could lend support to the idea that the
construct builders were the alabaster
lords it looks like the lookout stones
are lined up with the golems to block
the way to the coliseum like they are
working in tandem this could lend
credence to the idea of them being built
by the same people or group also another
quick aside here we find some of the
stones set up in ball formation from the
get-go ready to explode if we get too
close maybe we can call these versions
of the enemies the guard stones and the
ones standing at attention with their
eyes looking around can be the lookout
stones one is more guardy and one is
more lookouty and we get to use both
names they do act different as these
guard stones are the only in the game
that attack you outright the only ones
that do so that i can tell at least so i
think that it makes sense to give them
their own name we get to use both names
and we get a little distinction in the
kinds of guard lookout stones okay end
of aside in terms of whether or not the
stone lords are the mech civilization we
don't have too many other options to
choose from in game there are the
beastmen of pharah missoula who have
been around since the previous age and
are likely one of the first forms of
intelligent life in the lands between
rocket makes a tie between them and the
lords through a shared connection to the
dragons remember skins of stone but i
find it hard to think that the beast men
even if they used to be less feral were
the construct builders the tarnished
archaeologist has a great video
exploring the beastmen and their
environmental lore and i highly
recommend you go watch that to learn
more about the ancient lands between and
the inspiration of the design of lots of
pharah missoula it's a very interesting
video that goes over a lot of the
details and i don't think those details
lend a lot of credence to the idea that
the beastmen were the builders of all
these constructs so there might not be
any other likely candidates for the
ancient construct civilization slash
builders than the alabaster lords if we
say the civilization has to be something
from in game or reference in game or
that we'd like to see currently in the
world of the lands between then there
seems to be enough clues to think that
maybe the lords built both the stone
constructs in addition to the evergells
and lookout stones but we could also go
the other way of saying that the
creators of these other stone fixtures
simply aren't in game they maybe used to
be in lines between and now they aren't
anymore or maybe they were just made by
the dragons we know the dragons can take
a humanoid form and i'm sure they can
move a lot of stuff in their dragon form
as well and pharaoh missoula is flying
after all though i don't think it has
any special light like the elevators or
constructs rocket lugo thinks that phara
missoula may be powered by gravity magic
which would make lots of sense from a
floating city being powered by
anti-gravity view but the lack of purple
makes me hesitant to get fully on board
with this every other instance of
gravity magic has that purple and we
don't see it here or i haven't seen it
there isn't much more room to explore
about the creators of all of these stone
constructs so i'll leave this here let
me know what you think seems most likely
did the alabaster lords create all of
the stone constructs or just the
evergles and licko stones was it the
dragons or was it someone or some group
not even in the present day game let me
know your thoughts in the comments
but don't worry we're still not done
there are a few loose ends with our
stone worms starting with something
which i reference but still haven't
gotten to which is the drops that you
can get from killing the lookout stones
rune fragments and sanctuary stones and
maybe volcanic stones according to the
wiki both of these stones reference
ruins fallen from the sky and the rune
fragment specifically says that they are
believed to have once been part of a
temple in the sky
the obvious connection here is pharah
missoula so maybe i was too quick in
dismissing a connection to the floating
mausoleum the lookout stones also seem
to be made at least partially of these
fragments with bits of the orange gold
of the ruined fragments in their spheres
this would strengthen the connection
even more but still leaves us in the
dark about the acute specifics did the
alabaster lords create these only after
pharam azula started to crumble trying
to come up with a timeline would be
tough but i'd be interested to see your
attempts in the comments
we can also ask again if the lookout
stones are broken they don't attack on
sight and they even let us free blind so
they're not doing a good job of keeping
anyone locked up a possible explanation
would be that they only attack those
sealed away by the original creators and
now that the jails are just used by
literally anyone from the carrions to
the dragon knights the lookout stones
don't get any authorization code say to
actually attack and defend any of these
random new inmates or maybe since they
are lookouts they only look and report
sending info back to some alabaster lord
hq but if we think of all of them as
guard zones we see they do a poor job of
guarding so i'd say they're probably
just kind of broken as i said earlier in
the video there's also plenty we could
talk about with the evergles themselves
the people that are trapped inside
whether it's right to keep people
eternally locked up or the effects of
solitary confinement in a pocket
dimension might have on one's mind but
none of this really has to do with our
friendly stoneworms so i won't explore
them here in any case these lookout
stones don't do a whole lot they look
and they go boom when you attack they do
have some unique and goofy attacks which
is interesting that the devs would spend
time making unique attacks and
animations but then nothing would get
put in the lore or text references which
describes or even names these guys in
game a very unique enemy in gameplay and
design gets no unique description or
identification in the game story or
anything written in the game and because
of that there aren't many conclusions to
draw about the stones they be looking
out that's for sure and they give us
insight into some of the beings and
machinations of the past ages of the
lands between showing us how integrated
the alabaster lords may have been to
primeval life they definitely connect
the lords with pharam azula to some
degree but it's hard to say exactly how
is there anything else we can learn from
them tell me in the comments what kinds
of conclusions or ideas do you draw from
these mysterious one-eyed stone worms
and i think that will do it for my
exploration of the lookout stones i
think i covered every avenue we can to
get information about them i hope you've
enjoyed the video and if you did
consider subscribing to the channel or
becoming a patron on patreon i'd like to
thank you all for watching and be sure
to stick around because there is of
course more lore to explore i want to
look at some of the broader themes of
the game and upcoming videos kind of the
story the game is trying to tell us
through its enemies and lore and stories
i also want to explore these ideas in
relation to some of elden ring's
influences like berserk and the
philosophy that is present in these
works i'm a big philosophy guy if you
couldn't tell from the frenzy flame
video and i also want to do a full scale
critique sometime in the not too distant
future well that's about it for me let
me know what you think about these video
ideas and the lookout stones in the
comments thanks again for watching and
i'll see you in the next video peace